Goodnight buddy.
Goodnight.
See you in the morning.
Yep.
Dad, are you really going to defeat the Ender Dragon?
I'm gonna try, buddy.
Goodnight.
Alright, I'm at the end portal.
You with me?
Hey guys, I'm here.
Everybody have enough arrows?
Yeah, yeah, I got the arrows.
Hold on, I'm getting some carrots.
Seriously?
They're good for your health.
Almost there.
I'm going in.
Let's keep going.
He was dead weight anyways.
Almost got him, almost got him.
I'm taking too much damage.
One more hit.
Yes!
Who got him?
Who is that?
I know who it is.
I couldn't sleep.
Thanks for the assist!
Thanks!
It was a good job, kiddo.
We won, we won!
That was awesome!
Ah, OK, made it!
Where's this dragon?
We already did it.
You're late.
Maybe wait for me next time.
Getting a little help from my little guy.
That's my way to play.
Nintendo Switch.